election wise what's changed with
election over the years yeah but I I
trace it back to the end of Bush's
Administration the one I work for George
W bush and as a result of the war in
Iraq and how
this divisive the war became and the
opposition to Bush over the war became
the Democrats started to call him a war
criminal now I never previously heard I
was just referring to George H.W bush
calling somebody a clown and being
criticized all of a sudden now you're a
war criminal attorney general Al
Gonzalez you're a war criminal
the language the tone things just start
to change social media is now invented
it didn't exist when I was in office it
came at the end of the Bush years and
into the Obama years that allowed people
just to let it rip with no filter and
people said the meanest nastiest things
on social media and that just became
part of the parlance that enveloped us
as opposed to the older decorum where
people said show some respect don't say
those things keep your thoughts to
yourself those old-fashioned Notions
sticks and stones
and then it got worse Obama comes into
office and certainly he was divisive
president he had very low regard for
Republicans Republicans had low regard
for him Donald Trump of course said he
wasn't born here which was wrong he said
he was born in Kenya which was wrong
it just starts the it continued it
snowballed and now again social media
piles on top of it where people agree to
these things
and then it just continued on and then
oh and Trump's win Trump wins in 2016
and half of America becomes unhinged and
says it's because of Russia collusion
and and the whole Trump's illegitimate
and for all the criticism of Republicans
being election deniers which is a valid
criticism
it was started by the Democrats in 2016
when they never accepted Donald Trump's
election
so all of this has made a pitted America
pitted camps I'm a Believer though Pat
in the pendulum swings in this country
and it always swings back toward the
center always back to reasonableness and
moderation because that's the
temperament of the American people we're
going through a phase we're going
through a swinging phase you think we're
going to go back to being diplomatic
like you think because the one thing is
there anything that's not going to
change is there anything that's going to
change I think like what I think is
going to change hey we're going to go
left oh my God we're going too far ah
we're going to go right oh we're going
too far right oh we're going to go I
think that part may be right but are we
you know at a point where you know how
they say well the first time you have
sex and you lose your virginity it's
like they're in the second third nobody
and then it's like oh let it rip you
know you just you're single you're
you're not even thinking about it and
what's a completely different story but
the first time is the first time then it
becomes normal are we living in the
trolling era where this uh Jake Paul
This Dana White this Conor McGregor
Gregor Trump Elon Musk where trolls are
winning so it's becoming a Playbook to
say I have to learn how to troll not
that these folks are trolls they're
learning how to troll they're learning
how to poke and schools and you know if
you go to regular debates a class you
take they don't teach you on how to
handle trolls they don't teach you on
those kinds of things they say well when
you debate you have to respect your
opponent and you have to go based on
this and then all of a sudden boom
atrocious if you don't know how to
address that do you think the trolling
is here that's not going away and a name
calling and all of that or are we
gradually going to go back to being
extremely diplomatic to each other we
are living through a very vituperative
era trolls and just breakdown of
old-fashioned treat people with dignity
and respect even if you disagree with
their opinions
the solution to that is easy one day a
leader will run for president who
actually means it and can rise up and
unite people we have politicians who run
now saying I'm a uniter I won't do this
or I won't do that then they get into
office and right away get divisive
we're going to get sick of this and one
day a president's going to tap into that
and a president who is genuinely
somebody who people respect he treats
people with dignity he looks at the
other party and says I disagree with
your ideas I'm going to defeat you on
your ideas
but I respect the fact that you love
this country too and that is the
Hallmark of America we have always had a
level of unity acceptance tolerance that
unites us As Americans makes us the Envy
of the world and a Ronald Reagan style
candidate who comes out and reminds
people about what this country the city
on a hill can be like is going to have a
huge following
by temperament not necessarily by
ideology by temperament because we can
get tired of the vituperative era and
the Pendulum will swing I think so you
think you think it's good I do so so
give me uh uh I know everybody says uh
you know we need another Ronald Reagan
to show up right and we need another you
know John F Kennedy Democrats will say
we need a Clinton temperament to show up
because how you as well then Obama
showed up but do you think
um a person like that can show up and
take all the constant criticism and get
the media to turn around and be kind and
gentle and soft to them not about the
media it's about the country it's about
the people yes I believe that the the
thing about the presidency and whoever
emerges to run for president
they single-handedly have the ability to
set an example this is what presidents
do and when the example like President
sets is to belittle is to continue the
vituperative streak that our nation is
in the middle of people follow
when a president actually Rises up and
people read it and see it and believe
that this guy actually does focus on
Unity
even if he audiologically he's different
from you or me
that president has a chance that's
leadership it's about leadership so what
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valutamin it
says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
our black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]